right. I work in is working is
it working yeah it is working.
Anybody hear me in the back
near me the back. Hello okay
closer why. That is great
that's right speech written by
my staff you'll I can't read it.
Well welcome everybody to the
this beautiful C. S. U.
Dominguez hills campus what a
great place to be for all you
tore us out there thank you for.
I mean if the dissipating and
to our conversation is David.
For those who may not know this
hearing on student success is
part of our- two year statewide
tour of college campuses now I
can hear that. Our Senate
committee on student success
this is a- we've been we've
been engaged in a two year
effort going to college
campuses throughout our our
wonderful state to explore
student needs in their ability
to succeed in the classroom.
Out last year earlier this
spring we visited Sacramento
state today we're here at the
mega sales tomorrow we're going
to be a Cal Poly Pomona. And
it's important that for those
of us in in the lawmaking world
that. We don't just to pass
laws and hope that they get
implemented but it's important
that we get in on the ground.
Experience and knowledge about
what's happening here. At the
mega cells in colleges around
our state and that and that's
why we're here. For me coming
back to this campus is a little
bit of deja vu I out loud I was
last here forty years ago.
Things have changed just a
little bit. I was a student
body president at San Diego
state. And with that as a part
of the California state student
association we go to campuses
everyone to. Collaborate with
our fellow students and got the
opportunity to come here to
Dominguez hills back then it's
fun to come back. Right now.
And another thing of note is
that up at least for me and I
maybe from my colleagues as
well. I was double book today.
That's like how did that happen
will. Last week governor
Newsome's office called and
said would you come to meet
with the governor this morning
in Sacramento and I said well I
kind of have a conflict.
Because we have this hearing.
And he said that I'm gonna sign
your bill. And what's the bill.
Well together with my
colleagues. We pass the largest
education bond bill ever put
forward in California out of
the Senate and the assembly.
The governor the governor this
morning is signing it. And I
think it has it has been signed
provided provides over six
billion dollars. For higher
education facilities in
California six billion dollars
including two billion for the
California state universities
which to make a sales. Is
eligible for a- but even with
the governor's signature today
it's not a done deal that will
appear on the March ballot
March primary ballot next year
and I know this isn't a time to
talk about politics but I hope
you'll pay attention to what's
on your ballot. Next year. So
the mission of the select
committee on student success is
to gather experts together. For
discussion not to push a
specific agenda. But rather to
learn best practices and
innovations to improve student
success. And our focus is on
students and putting them on a
path to graduation. And we're
focus not just on what's
happening in the classroom and
the ability to get through
university with a degree were
also focusing. On hunger
housing and mental health
issues. We know that if
students are able to take care
of their basic needs that
they're not gonna do well to
stay in school. And certainly I
am hoping that with our great
panel of experts are going to
hear from a few minutes that
will learn more about. How
that's happening here at
Dominguez hills. I we have two
campuses in the state the gist
of. Talk about the positive
models that we have out there.
A Sacramento state in San Jose
state where their participation
for your grad program is
extraordinary thousands of kids
are in that commitment every
year. And their graduate at
their graduation rates are
going up. In in a wonderful way
and. The chancellor's office I
know we're gonna hear from them
in a few minutes with that Mr
gold. At least they're report
shows that here at the mega
sells only about a hundred and
twenty students are
participating in that four
year. Graduation pathway I have
over thirteen thousand enrolled
here and we want to understand
that issue we'll hear from the
chancellor's office to get us
perspective. And then we'll get
to digging down in the details
here to make a sales. But I'm
joined here by some wonderful
colleagues in the legislature.
I wanted to use them to give
them a chance to make any kind
of interest introductory
remarks that they like to make.
But on my left is senator Steve
Bradford. Represents the magus
hills is an alumni. Of this
campus. Yeah that down we got a
de. We'll see is a great Holly
here in the Senate been a great
advocate for a higher education
institutions certainly
Dominguez hills is that. De
near and dear to his heart and
I want to welcome him and
invite him to make a remark
she'd like to make. Thank you
senator Glazer and let's give
him a round of applause for
putting the store on and.
Making college chicks us a
party and not just for the
legislature but it should be
for all of California to make
sure that the young folks are
for older adults who choose to.
Attend a university whether to
see if you use C. or private
institution I have the means to
succeed it's often. Assume
simply because one might have a
GPA might out with the
scholarship or whatever it will
cover all your- expenses for
college and that's the farthest
thing from the truth what we
found I have found out in the
last year have. I have five
colleges in my district you
counted community colleges you
count. To make a sales and I
Jeff next is a little bit I've
Long Beach state. We have food
pantries almost on all those
campuses and it speaks volumes
to the fact that there are.
Young folks going coming to
school on a daily basis home
we're going home longer we also
had a piece of legislation this
year. Trying to allow students
to sleep in their cars on
campus because again we're
dealing with the number. Of
homeless students here in
California. Then I decided
about. The new housing that
will be coming on cal state
Dominguez hills in the coming
years because it's vitally
important for far too long this
is pan team does a commuter.
Campus and we want the students
to have a real connection to
the university and I think
housing is part. Of that
important role so I'm excited
about the discussion today. And
I would just be back in sept
way on a piece of legislation
that the governor of side. Last
Monday my bill that I co
authored with a- Nancy Skinner
SP tools six. The fare paid to
play out and it's got a whole
lot of discussion about why
should we- allow young folks
who are in college to play
sports to monetize your name
like this an image. Much for
the same reason we're talking
have the discussion today just
because you're a scholarship
athlete. Doesn't mean you can
cover all your expenses if in
college. College expenses is
more intuition and books we
have found even though for
scholarship athletes many of
them go to bed hungry on a
daily basis. Don't have
spending money in their pocket
so this is going to afford it
so this is the nexus of dealing
with. The high cost of college
not only in California but
across the nation so I'm
excited about the discussion
today. Look forty hearing from
all wrecks Richard. Right thank
you Steven red laces on that
legislation that's a great
accomplishment for. Our student
athletes who I don't get the
respect and attention that they
deserve. Another colleague in
the Senate. Is here senator
Archuleta. You where did you go
to college. Rihanna and Bob
that was another great
supporter of higher education
this year in the legislature
voted for the- higher education
by it's great to have you here
Bob anything you want to say to
welcome. See if this works.
This work there is. Yes in my
thirty second Senate district
we have Biola. College Wiener
college riddles college and
real Honda college and- so. And
I'm looking at this list. Of
colleges in the rates that the
graduation rates and- and I
just think of so many of. My
family members that went to
some of the schools. But I
guess I'm I come as a parent as
well. Because I have five
children and they all obviously
did well. At school I have one
son out of as C. one daughter
out of pepper dying one
daughter out of Jeff minute two
sons out of west point. So they
were able to get there degrees
in the four years and so on.
But my concern is the focus is
up on the student's ability. To
understand that they can
achieve the same thing for
years. And my concern is are we
getting the word out to the
students. When we understand we
have fourteen thousand students
and rolled. We only have about
two hundred in the program.
It's something wrong here and
we're not here to be punitive
in any way shape or form but we
want to be informed and we want
to be informative as well. And
you heard both my colleagues
say that. The governor just
signed a bill what money will
be coming. So if money is going
to be the issue Ben. It all
that means that the future
looks bright. That means that
we're going to make these
adjustments and I'm thinking
that's what. I'm looking to
hear and see that that cal
state to make this is going to
be part of the future. To open
those dork bring these kids at.
But as center Bradford had
mentioned. We have kids that
obviously or sleep in their
cars and have a- not even have
a good meal for the- entire day
so these are issues were looked
we've got to look at because
we've got to keep them healthy
and strong and- be able to
participate. And then of course
a lot of drop off because they
have family issues they want to
support a family we understand
that. But if we can and Senate
in Senate died them in such a
way and I don't know what that
and Senate will be. But we've
got to come together with the
plan an idea. That they can see
the future right around the
corner for years to come just
like that and we want that
success to be your success. So
I'm here to listen to learn.
And to participate anyway I can
and I welcome the opportunity
and certainly as a freshman
senator. I am ready to
participate anyway I can't
thank you thank you Senate
Archuleta and- to be successful
in an lawmaking in Sacramento
you have to have great partners
in the in both houses not just
the Senate. And my colleagues
here but in the assembly and we
have a great partner here. In a
seven member al there's two G.
thank you for you went to
Berkeley I de Berkeley. But
you've been a great champion of
higher education and you have a
lot of constituents that go to
here to address fills and we're
so happy that you've joined us
here today so thank you very
much. Sarah Glazer and good
afternoon everyone my name is
research and I have the
privilege. Of along with center
Bradford represented the South.
Bay in the California State
Legislature my district.
Because from. A Gardena down
through pals birdies. I I'm a
former toward school board
member and I know that a good
number toward students I don't
know. Anyone here from Torrance.
Not today okay what time all
right. I know a good number of
my constituents attend cal
state Dominguez hills and so
thank you very much senator I.
I sit on the assembly budget
committee on education funding
and so I've- heard. Many
students testify about the
challenges their students face
today whether it's housing and
security. Of food in security
mental health challenges and so
you know I'm- familiar with the
challenges that that many of
your students face today but I
need to learn more. And so
that's why I'm here thank you
very much thank you thank you
with family member well we have
enough a formal welcome here to
the campus by our provost.
Michael's back now I want to
invite him up and if he's
coming up let me mention he's a
former. Professor chair and
dina cal state university
Northridge or work for twenty
five years his academic
background is in special
education. The master's and PhD
in that field I see that you
spent some time in my district.
Chip college in Livermore
working in the area of
disabilities. Thank you for
your service there and we know
that you're involved in helping
lead Dominguez hills. And their
efforts in improving student
success in ensuring access for
the underserved and diverse
communities that. That you
serve your thank you for
welcoming us your campus. Give
so welcome to our campus see if
we can get this microphone
working as well. One two three.
Good. Hello hello okay there we
go so welcome on behalf of
president Thomas parm or live
in the university president he
sends his regrets he couldn't
join us today he's doing noble
work back in Chicago Illinois
so he's attending the Hispanic
association of colleges and
universities with ten of our
student leaders a wonderful
experience for them so he sends
his regrets but his warm
welcomes as well also I want to
make sure that as I welcome our
guests to the campus we are in
a rare area of growth we'll
talk talk about that in a
couple minutes in my opening
remarks. But I want to make
sure that if you want to feel
the love on campus as senator
Glazer felt today because he
had teddy coming give him a hug
and they took a selfie as soon
as he came into the student
union we want to make sure you
use the right hand signal when
you're on campus so we don't
want to do Longhorns hook them
or matadors who wanted to the
Toro so it's got to have the
snout on it so if you're on
campus showing students love
makes you're doing this in the
background you get a lot of
love from our students in our
community so welcome. As I said
before this is an exciting time
to be on our campus we are at
an all time high in terms of
our enrollment last year at
this time we enrolled fifteen
thousand seven hundred students
as of census this year where it
seventeen thousand twenty seven
students on the campus of those
students we have two thousand
five hundred freshmen thirty
three hundred transfer students
and as you all know we have the
most diverse school in the
entire C. issue system. To give
you some of the information
here eighty two point 7% of our
students and our freshman class
are under represented minority
students 73% Pell eligible 66%
are first generation students
at our universities this is
critical about the needs of our
students and I will tell you
also that its key for us at cal
state Dominguez hills because
we are still for filling the C.
issue mission which is about
access and. Completion also
you'll notice me take a torn
our campus. That were in a rare
place where we have new
buildings that have been added
to campus we have two academic
buildings the first two
academic buildings in twenty
five years. On this campus. A
science and innovation
building. Which opens fall of
twenty twenty just to our south
here we have a brand new
innovation and instruction
building that will be opening
in fall twenty one which will
house our college of business
administration public policy.
And just as importantly we have
new student housing that is
slated to open in the spring
twenty twenty one. Which is
going to have an additional
five hundred beds. Our
president is fond of saying
that in order for us to be
successful with students on
campus we need need to make
sure they spend more time on
campus. He has to find that as
of waiting pinball
interactions. It works with us
with some of the students
coming in the freshman class we
have to describe what a pinball
machine actually dot so we go
through gyrations of showing
how the ball works well works
so forth. But I will tell you
as you look at the campus and
it is a significant day.
Because assembly bill forty
eight will wind up providing
much needed infrastructure for
our campus we have ninety
million a hundred million
dollars and need. To build up
the infrastructure on campus.
The other thing that I wanted
to say is that we also have
invested quite a bit in our
personnel on campus we are
hiring about thirty tenure
track faculty per year. We are
improving the culture of non
tenure track faculty on the
campus to provide a lot of our
instruction. And we're also
building a culture of staff
also in support for them. We
also aspire to in the president
would say this if you were here
we aspire to be a student ready
university and if any of you
have seen this a lot of the
work that's coming out in the
field. Is that instead of us
talking about students being
college prepared and career
ready. We have to be. Student
ready at our university and we
think you'll find it to make a
sells you hear from our panel
of experts. We truly are
embracing this notion of being
student ready. That means
making sure that we are not
putting it on the shoulders of
students we're talking about
how we better performance
university to support those
students. The three areas that
we have a mission to in the cal
state system I've been. The
system thirty year. We've
always been about access in the
LA based. Right now just so you
know we are the only one out of
five C. S. U. campus is still
open in terms of access. With
the only non impact the campus
in the LA basin of what this
means is. That that that
students were placed balle the
Mingus hills is their choice
for quality C. S. U. education.
So much so that we recently had
a redirection policy in the
state. Where three hundred in
addition three hundred
additional students came to our
campus. As their choice when
they could not have another
option in the LA basin this is
significant for us. We also
develop really strong inner
segmental partnerships so.
You'll know that we place on an
average three hundred tutors
out in Compton unified in
Gardena valley as well. And we
put those those students out
there. Their undergraduate
students working with local K.
through twelve classrooms. We
also have mobile fab labs that
were de donated by Toyota that
we use to reach out to the
committee for stem education.
And we have strong partnerships
with the committee colleges
most notably El Camino college.
Where we have a computer
science collaboration. Only the
second one in the state of
California in the C. S. U. the
other one being a moderate. The
other thing we focus on is on
completion and you'll hear a
lot from the panel today about
completion. Of certainly on the
six metrics that we look at on
five of those six were making
good progress. On the six
measure for your graduation
will be talking about that. We
are making progress moderates
but progress to just make sure
you have some level setting. In
two thousand fourteen the four
year graduation rate at this
campus was five percent. This
past year it's risen now up
212% and we're on to projection
it sixteen percent. In about a
year from now. So our
aspirations or if you think
about that over five short
years. We've tripled wrong the
mark to triple our four year
graduation rates. Something
that is the present with safe
use here we can do better we
must do better for students to
be out there. The second issue
for us the third issue for us
actually is the only. With
connected to. Completion is
what we do to address student
needs we are foremost among the
C. issue campuses and providing
something called affordable
learning solutions and this is
where we provide courses. At
either low cost or no cost cost
the students. We've been
calculated of within the past
year we have four hundred fifty
faculty that participate in
this program the leader in the
C. issue. And we save students
close to a million dollars in
terms of money they would
rather spend on course
materials. I will channel the
president for minute that's an
applause line the million
dollars. In terms of basic
needs will talk about I did
provide. A little graphic on
the table there we will provide
these in the back. Cal state
Dominguez hills been a
partnership with apple their
enterprise system and we've
developed the C. S. U. D. H.
heats up. This app will be of
use to all students across the
campus and one of the things it
does which is pretty
revolutionary. Is that it sets
it up so that any student on
campus can find out when an
event is taking place where
food is being provided. And
therefore can go to that event
receive free meals free food
and doesn't have to encounter
the stigma of walking into a
separate building on campus.
This is innovative relates to
the partnerships we do with the
larger community. I want to
thank my comp my colleague got
Chris my requests are vice
president. Of information
technology for champion this
another applause line. And then
the third area as I mentioned
the C. issue system we've
always been about access were
now about completion with
graduation innovation twenty
twenty five. But in the C.
issue Dominguez hills is the
leader in going to the third
area that we haven't talked as
much about. Which is thriving
and in our system it's going to
all be about thriving what
happens to students after they
graduate. We have a saying on
campus are model was once a
Toro always a Toro. So we're
committed to lifelong learning
of our students we want to be
able to provide Mike or
certificates micro credentials
badging. So that the student
graduates from here five years
ten years fifteen years. Is
going to be able to get re
skilling upscaling to keep them
on the job market and being
resilience that's another thing
that we're really committed to.
And I would say without also if
you saw recently in The New
York Times. There was a review.
About social mobility in the op
crossed all colleges the United
States. In the state of
California Dominguez hills was
ranked fourth out of a hundred
sixty eight colleges. In terms
of so just for mobility this
means upon graduating. Two or
more quintiles and earnings
after they graduate university
for me that's the mark of
success and something that we
will continue to use again once
the Torah always a Toro. There
many more things I was given
five minutes so I've condensed
a lot of it so we can get to
our panel but it's our honor to
have you on campus and I'll
turn it back to you now senator
Glazer. Thank you provost at
great overview and your campus
is on the rise it's great to be
be here and hear the stories
and learn from what you're
doing here as we learn from all
the campuses that we visit. I
wanna I welcome our first
witness set that's gonna share
their expertise with us today
it's Jeff gold he's the
assistant vice chancellor for
student success initiatives at
the California State
University. You have a global
view of how we're doing around
California not just the
Dominguez hills view which
you're gonna hear from and just
a few minutes but- I would love
for you to talk about the C. S.
use graduation initiative the
twenty twenty five targets that
have been set. How we do and
where we go on right maybe
where some places are we need
improvement welcome circle
fantastic. Thank you so much.
Actually get real close in as
well. I just want to start off
by thanking you folks I mean
especially as we were talking
this morning senator Glazer
about turning down an
invitation from the governor to
celebrate the signing of your
bill. I think that says
something to me should say
something to everyone in this
room. The fact that you're all
here giving this time the fact
that this road show continues.
From your many stops and
tomorrow you'll be at Pomona.
It sends a signal to everyone
in our office to everyone in
the on our campuses but I think
more importantly throughout the
state of California. But this
is important to you that you
value this. And so just let's
give the senators a big hand
for their time can. So they get
started I'm I'd probably take a
step back quickly to just give
us a little bit of context as
many of you know. Three years
ago we got together as a system
with cross representative group
from all campuses different.
Positions within the campuses.
To set some of the most
ambitious goals. For completion
inequity. We set goals so high
that the CSU system is known as
a public comprehensive
university system. We aim to be
first and best amongst our
peers when it comes to
graduation rates and equity. As
proverbs back to mention we
have always been known we take
great pride in the fact that
our student body. Our diverse
student body. Medics and looks
just like the great diversity
in the state of California.
Where we've needed to be much
more intentional is with. The
completion rates with.
Facilitating the group that
path to high quality degree
fall of our students. And so
right now as we fast forward
three years from those states
only set as ambitious goals.
I'm thrilled to be able to
report that we are doing
tremendously well on almost all
of our goals and let me explain.
As a student in the C. S. C.
when I see that there's some
students the room today there
has never been a better time.
To be at the C. S. C. with
regards to student success. Let
me say that again because I
think it's so important. In the
entire history of the C. S. U.
there has never been a time
when you were not more likely
to graduate to succeed as a
student then right now. And
that doesn't happen by accident
that happens because the
intentionality. Happens I
mention because you're willing
to make this a top priority for
yourself. That throughout our
campuses whether its
administrators faculty staff
our presidents. Just as an
example our trustees. Require
every two months that they get
an update on our graduation
initiative they want to know in
every single meeting.
Regardless of what's on their
agenda they required an update
for the grad initiative. If you
had been on campus I imagine I
would almost be sure. A month
and a half ago you would have
heard present apartment as
complication. Talk about the
graduation initiative get
students dreaming from day one
get faculty thinking from the
beginning of the school year.
Of the importance of
completion. That happened here
like it happened on twenty two
other campuses. As we go
through the arteries of the
campus whether its faculty
staff. Administrators we are
all thinking and doing the same
things. Being intentional about
how we can better support our
students. And that's why we see
the improvements with regard to
the equity. I have to remind us
that we are looking back. I'm
somewhat. So it's almost like
looking at the stars. In seeing
them the. The reflectance
cutbacks for six years later.
But we have made some really
important progress. In terms of
policy. So in terms of equity
we have made about a one or two
percentage point improvement
for the first time in our act
by closing Mike equity gaps of
this last year. We have a lot
more work to do there. But that
comment about the stars is
because when you look at what
happened a year ago. As many of
you know was the very first
time in fact I think you
highlighted the set your forum.
At Santa Monica college about a
year and a half ago. We changed
as a system a policy that was
unequal unfair to us a
significant number of our
incoming students. In
particular students of color in
low income students. And by
doing that we got rid of with
the stroke of a pen. The
remedial education program that
we had which basically said
students at the same time.
Welcome to this yes you work
five year here. But if you
don't jump through these hoops
to finish these courses within
a year. You're gonna. And so
you can imagine
disproportionately. Students of
color low income students first
generation students were in
that group that was relegated
to those courses. But I
couldn't be more proud in fact
I think for all of us in this
room. This will be one of the
most important. Policy changes
for student success in the in
our lifetimes. After one year
of that policy change we're
seeing that eight times the
number of students of this last
year. Within one year eight
times the number of students.
Were able to complete their
general education math
requirement in that very first
year. So maybe in closing just
at a high level what I've
described is I often get asked
in formal and informal
sessions. How are you guys
moving then you know how are
you able to be successful with
your system for its on the
graduation initiative. I really
have to two pieces of. Two
responses to that question one
as I've mentioned is that
intentionality. Across the
board from our external
partners to state legislatures.
To our our internal faculty
staff administrators there's an
unwavering commitment to
student success in the
intentionality that goes with
it. Number two is very
important and I know it's early
in the year to be mentioning
this are talking about this.
But student success is not
free. A quick choirs money for
us to launch the courses to
support our students to higher
the tenure track faculty. To
teach those courses to have the
propria by users and the
wonderful support structures
that. Provost back in the
mentioned those are not free.
And so we really appreciate the
support of the state
legislatures along with the
governor's office to help us
be. Where we are now which is
close to the full funding. Of
the graduation initiative three
years and- so with that about
Beth final thank you I turn it
back over to you right thank
you doctor gold a couple of
questions for me and I want to.
Open up to my colleagues for
follow up as they see fit. As
he talked about the change in
remediation and we did hold a
hearing on that and I was very
pleased to see that policy
change because I think it was
discriminatory. At the same
time we hear that the trustees
are considering increasing.
Math requirements could you
address at that and maybe share
your same thoughts about
whether or not. You think we
may be heading now in a
different direction. That that
may have some affect on the-
the fit is within our
admissions yeah really. Really
good question I think we lose
a- really good question and so
the question is really about
what we're calling a
quantitative reasoning
requirement and it sounds like
semantics changing the word
from. Math quantitative
reasoning but what we're
looking to do with our board in
fact it'll go up for a vote
next month and skews me too
much. November is to ask that
our high school students who
come to us take an additional
course in additional a three G.
course. In something related to
math so when of course but you
know it can. Be to programming.
Of. Course find a course for
the such. And the idea. Not
only of their of the entrance
requirements. But also to
become better prepared to enter
into a discipline such as spam.
So what we're seeing now we
talk about equity gap says this
binary. Gap between graduation
rates between students. But if
we were to look at the graph at
the composition of students who
are graduating and spam versus
non stern for example. You see
significant. Said significant
variation in the students were
eligible and go into those more
high paying. More sought after
careers and so part of this
initiative overall for the
quantitative reasoning
requirement. Is to ensure that
our students not only have an
equable chance when they
answer. Once they enter they
have an apple opportunity to
choose a major. That will
prepare them for the future. So
there's no doubt that the whole
stem areas a place you want to
encourage student participation
and success and for their sake
and for California say. It's
there are many degrees are
offered on a campus and non
stem degrees. And I don't know
what that proportion as- where
that kind of quantitative
reasoning really isn't going to
find their success here in
college and in life. It's
certainly at. That's a similar
criticism of the standardized
testing requirements were so
much of it is based on your
success in math. And yet in the
humanities and political
science and sociology and so
many other. Fields of degree
that those those those just not
it's valuable and certainly we
want kids to have that well
rounded education which our
general education focuses on.
For everyone. But our week
again creating a gate. Rather
than an open door for so many
that just don't are dependent.
Irrespective of your
acknowledgement of how
important and valuable stem
students are. Yeah so I think
that maybe before I answer that
just the you know a little bit
of clarification as that had we
been looking to require for
example that everyone take
calculus or precalculus course.
I would completely agree with
you however when we talk to the
employers we go out to the
community and that's one of the
top skill sets the graduates
require all of the mentioned
this quantitative reasoning
it's this financial literacy
it's the ability to use numbers
and logic. So we are not just
to be clear talking about all
students being required to take
a calculus class were talking
about them having additional
practice. In that fluency with
new numeracy that will help
them second party question I
think is a really important one
and if you've been watching our
board meetings and watching the
community engagement. There's
been a very lively and I think
hardening debate about this and
the truth is we will never know
exactly what will happen six
years from now so the policies
that excuse me seven years from
now in terms of access. Policy
has a seven year window running
up to it where we have the
opportunity to get better help
help create better partnerships
with our case while partners to
ensure that the very worried
you have the concern that we
share does not happen. And that
window as we talk as we talk
about preparing. Teachers and
students as well for this new
requirement that the next time
we've also built in a kind of a
do no harm clause so the idea
is that you are. From an
underserved school de in the
fall you are not able to take
those courses that I mentioned
kind of the computer
programming financial literacy
or any type of science or math
course. You you will not be
held you'll be held harmless in
terms of your ability to come
to the C. issue. That Schering.
Those thoughts in order I do
watch all the trustee meetings.
Yeah we are paying attention.
Some of us. Let me also let me
go now to. Another space which
is. The in concert. He among
the campuses on their four year
into your trap programs. We're
gonna talk about Tom and
Gisele's in a few minutes but
let's step away from the
biggest fills. Data that you
provided as it breaks down
every campus that's
participating there are
significant differences. And
some of them are very positive
and encouraging like at
Sacramento and San Jose and
others like it cal state LA it
is just what's going on and
that doesn't seem like. That
that there's really commitment
to the program and we're gonna
talk about that in terms of.
The ability of a student even
to know about that for your
track and that's an issue I
happen to make us cells and
want to hear more on but- how
are you tracking the
consistency of application I
know you say comes up a
trustees meeting that's good.
And as I understand it it's a
part of the presidential
reviews which is good. But how
engaged are you conceding the
advertising that's going on on
the campus is just to have kids
get into the program let alone
having to be successful within
the program yeah that's a good
question and I think it's
important to note that there
are programs separate from the
California problems promise.
That aren't exactly the same in
letter but they are for example
Phoenician for type programmer
complete into so before the
legislation there were some
campuses that were already you
know reaching out and having
these types of arrangements
with their- with with their
incoming students both freshman
and transfers. And so I think
that discrepancy really has to
do with where folks are working
offices are or they have been
it just takes awhile for them
to can okay message out there I
know a colleague of mine was at
the counter conferences for the
entire. State of California for
this do you. Just months. Five
in caps there's talk. The
college props and made sure
that people knew counselors
know that adviser it you too
bye. To let them know that this
opportunity exists. So I think
that there's a couple things I
think you're right to say that
there's it unequal
implementation of the
California promised throughout
the state. And that you're
seeing strong growth in some
places and not as quick up
taken others. But I also think
that we need to look beneath
that to see that. For students
who don't check the box for
California promise. There are
other programs that are very
similar and in fact. You don't
provide stagnant talked about
his graduation rates tripling
over the last five years. As
the system right now we are at
about twenty five and a half
percent having started at
nineteen. Again none of us are
proud and want to stand back on
our laurels about where we are.
But we have moved the way that
we talk about graduation we
have moved the way that we
frame it and we have moved the
way that. Our faculty or staff
at our administrators
especially advisors. Are are
are having people. Get ready
for that. Very good and I up
when I go to my colleagues for
their followers but- I
encourage you to. As M. perhaps
you do go to any campuses
website. And say where do I
find the Phoenician four or the
cal promise whatever you wanna
call it. How hard is it for me.
To find that that program that
exists here. On a campus of I
want to get through in four
they're going to help me get
through it for and I. I think
if you take that challenge. You
will be challenged. It will be
very difficult to find it here
at to make a sells it takes six
clicks. Six links to try to
find the California promise
program here to make the cells
and to make this hills is not
unique in that. It just doesn't
seem to be up the promotional
efforts to inform kids that
that I can see in you may be in
a better position to see it but
I. Encourage you to try to take
that take that challenge.
Senate artillery you had a
follow up question yes thank
you I'd like to acknowledge the
provost because your- passion I
could feel it. That you know
where you're at and you realize
you've got to get to that next
level and I understand that
like knowledge that. And you we
can be successful if you don't
realize that we're not
successful and then to
implement the plans and
obviously the- the faculty the
students all have to feed into
that. Same yeah. But I would
think you meet. Really have a-
big punch in this thing. Is to
reach out for the to your
students. The ones are coming
in from the community colleges.
As if they've got two years
invested they got two years ago
you can immediately. Implement
a plan that'll get your right
up there. Because these numbers
are. Somewhat embarrassing to
be quite honest with you. And
thank god you're here. Because
now you can change with every
everyone here. And this could
be the first step. To go
forward. So I'm thinking and
here's my question to you Mr
gold. What what do you think
you need to do to. To bring in
that goes to your students.
That will help your numbers
because we need to get these
numbers up. And I know we got
the issues pertaining to. To
healthcare and food and- and
how Jean everything else. But
these to your students I think
they're already on the path.
What do you think yes we need
that to your standard talk
about communicable edge
students who come here right.
And graduated to yeah I think
so yeah. I think that we are
already seeing it in our
numbers at as a as a system. We
set a goal at the time I
believe our our to your I.
tuition rates were about thirty
percent. Or less for up to your
transfers there now sitting at
38% with the goal of forty
five. So book I'm I hear your
Senate I always in this
uncomfortable position. Of I
don't know some defensive
because not for a minute we
think that forty five is the
end all be all we want that
number be even higher. But in
terms of setting a stretch goal
of 45% of our students.
Completing in two years were
now sitting at about thirty
eight in our preliminary
numbers say that we're going to
be this year so. We're just
calculating and finishing
calculating the graduation rate
data. For degrees through
summer. And so that's why I was
back to mention that he has
some numbers are preliminary
our preliminary numbers are
telling us. They were to get
even closer about forty five.
We have room travel. I think it
does take a little bit of time
and we're seeing that happening
now. For students to a at the
community colleges be aware
that this even exist we're
seeing those numbers exist. And
then on our end to arrange the
curriculum in such a way that
we facilitate every step of the
way. For students to have that
opportunity to complete in two
years. Let me follow up on his
chair. That we have the
interview process when they're
coming in. About the exit
process when you find a
student. Who's about to say I
can't handle it I don't have
the patience I got to that they
get. I mean the sit down and
find out why. And how are we
losing you. And what what
should we have done differently
you have do you have that
process. Yeah I love it I would
not in the system office
because we don't have the
students there but many of our
campuses are doing exactly what
you're talking about and- not
even. Not only that I should
say but when there are warning
signs so sometimes when they
already have left it's too late
or they're about to leave. But
a couple steps before when the
signs are there that this is a
Steven our data tell us. That
the student is in danger of
leaving we have proactive
advising who read. Yeah but
visor to reach out and say let
me really better understand
what's going on. You need to
stand rolled. We need to do
more to support it to
graduation. Thank you. Okay Dr
gold thank you for your
testimony I. Hope you'll hang
around and now they come back
thank you. Well let me welcome
our first expert from the
campus. Doctor Meru Figueroa.
Thank you for being here you
are the interim associate vice
president. Who has taken over
the graduation rate and
Phoenician for and transfer
into program here to make a
sales as I understand it. I
told you the university wide
academic advisement testing and
learning center. Activities
here on the campus is that
right. Thank you for your good
work there you previously at
Northridge or some pattern
going on here. Were you served
as a coordinator for freshman
programs. Were you provided
that counseling to first time
freshmen. Dealing with academic
and transitional issues and-
and all the rest so we
appreciate your expertise to
look for your testimony. Today
thank you for being here. Well
thank you so much for the
opportunity to share our story
with you. I know some of this
has already been surefire Provo
stand by Jeff as well. But
California state Dominguez
hills is born from the struggle
of the people that surrounded
the area. And although the
demographics of our local area
have shifted. The content the
community continues to reflect
the struggle and the
resiliency. A high percentage
of our students as you heard.
Falling to three high risk
categories which is spelled
recipients. Are in need of
additional academic support.
And belonged to historically
underserved population in
addition to that as you heard.
Percent of our students
identify as first generation
this is significantly higher
than the C. S. U. overall.
These all have been correlated
with low completion rates in
college. However this the
student characteristics are not
barriers to college completion
when appropriate academic
supports are in place. Rooted
in our institutional mission we
firmly believe in delivering
transformational education
experiences that emphasizes
equity accessing inclusion for
all students. We utilize these
three quartermaster rate a
holistic approach to supporting
our strings that begins in the
first year. Dominguez hills was
one of forty four campuses
selected to participate in ask
use the association of American
state colleges and universities
reimagining the first year.
That redesigned the first year
of college to create
sustainable change for student
success. In two thousand
fifteen Dominguez hills first
year experience lunch also
known as D. H. F. Y. E. and it
provided all of our incoming
freshmen an opportunity to have
a shared experience that
included four points a
proactive in intrusive
advising. And that's fine your
mentor or coach appear in peer
academic support in the form of
tutoring and supplemental
instruction that targeted are
historically high D. of W.
courses. A summer bridge
experience and a connection to
campus. At the forefront of all
of this is our faculty who have
supported who have stepped up
to the challenge of re
envisioning and re imagining
the court the curriculum to be
responsive inclusive and
engaging. Studies have
demonstrated the generation C.
students appreciate practical
real life experiences. They
want more hands on application
of course work and are
interested in applying them to
social issues that are
important to them. At the
Mingus hills faculty have maybe
intentional effort to create
high impact practices such as
the first year seminar or more
commonly known on our campuses
during seminar or fact in
faculty continuously developing
gauging scholarly experiences.
To support their transition
from high school to our
university with an intentional
focus on social issues advocacy
and career planning. Through
the nays competences as a guide
and niece is the national
association of college
employers. Faculty participate
in a learning community to
provide a space for critical
analysis in fact and reflection
with intentional professional
development sharing of best
practices and identifying
opportunities. The Dominguez
hills transfer learning
community launched in twenty
sixteen with a focus on
supporting our transfer
students. And career readiness
through our do the design your
life course which has
demonstrated increases in
career. Self advocacy agency
confidence and resilience. At
the same time we brought
together a unified in cross
divisional team of faculty
staff administrators and
students to analyze and address
Brokeback's to college
completion. This team developed
a pay it forward grant which is
awarded to students were
identified as having a specific
remote requirement preventing
them from graduating. Since
twenty sixteen four hundred and
thirty six awards were made to
students who committed to
completing this requirement and
last spring or summer term. 86%
of the students who were
awarded. The pay it forward
grant have completed and earned
a their degree. This is a total
of approximately four hundred
and seventy thousand dollars.
That have been funded by a our
academic affairs budget. The
remaining students all have
been supported to develop an
academic plan to move forward.
The California promises
instrumental in supporting the
objectives of the C. S. U.
twenty twenty five graduate
initiative. Here on our campus
known as a torrent Vassar
program which encompasses the
Phoenician for and that through
into. We've developed an
intentional program that is
high intensity and high touch
and provide students with the
opportunity to become involved
on campus through high impact
practices to help them be
successful. This over to who
stern Robert just a pie
participate have one on one
meetings with program
coordinators to develop there
to work for your plans. Meet
regularly with the academic
adviser they are connected to
their faculty advisors and the
major. They participate in
service learning and research.
And indeed with the career
center and the Torah learning
and testing center. Students
will participate in the
California promise programs
have tracked have been tracked.
And the data suggest that our
demonstrates I should say that
students successfully complete
their degrees and two or four
years. And four are on track to
do so. These students the
student success initiatives
that have brought together a
committed faculty students
staff and administrators. Have
been funded with one time
funding. And we thank you the
legislators and the
chancellor's office for the
support. For the support and
supporting our stern success
initiatives that have helped us
achieve as the probe was
mentioned and also Jeff our
graduation rates as you have
seen on the mountain big
building up in addition one
other significant move is the
student mean unit load. That we
have been projected for this
term at thirteen point one.
This is up from eleven in
twenty in twenty fourteen.
Given the enrollment growth C.
S. U. DHS experience we're at a
point in time we're we're
taking a critical look at how
to scale and sustain momentum
that we have built. Part of
looking at this is also
insuring the well being of our
students basic needs a mental
health issue had mention. Thank
you okay thank you doctor
Figaro I appreciate the
overview I a big fan of your
first year seminar I'm a big
fan of your pay it forward.
Grants and certainly I know I'm
joined by my colleagues on the
panel and doing everything we
can to. Create more one time
money or on going support and
the seventy five million I
think it was in the budget this
year I was on top of the
seventy five million. Before
but let me ask you this and I
know there's a person's.
Chances office so we can't like
have our own little private
conversation. If there was
something that you feel a what
are you not getting here. The
cells with some very
influential people here. On
this panel what are you not
getting that we can help you
get that can make you more
successful. So I think you know
Jeff did mention right
resources one time finding is
great and we greatly appreciate
it but it's about sustainable
funding to continue the work
that we have done what we did
at Dominguez hills we did not
have dedicated positions for
the Phoenician for or that
they're going to we did receive
the funding and we adjusted
positions we tweaked position
descriptions to be able to
support the work and what we
need is really dedicated folks
that are dedicated to the out
reach into the support into out
reaching also to our faculty.
Out you know because one piece
is also the student outreach
but it's also the faculty how
do we engage the faculty in the
process to build a these
mentorship opportunities to
build these coaching
opportunities for students
because we are also focusing
not only in the two and four
year graduation but we also
want them to continue to be
successful after the after they
graduate with that that's
graduate school or going back
to what purpose Agnes said
going into the into the private
sector in in their own
professional careers. So we're
gonna hear from the faculty in
just a moment but the big
question that I had coming here
and still remains and. It's not
just at when students get on
the track they want to get.
Four years or two years and
what the university's doing to
support that that all sounds
great we really wonderful. But
what surprised me most is how
few students are. Making
themselves available for that
for your tracks because they
don't know about it is because-
they know about it added the
thirteen thousand only a
hundred say ow I care. You talk
about the unit load being up
which is a great indicator. Of
a commitment to getting a
degree. If the if the average
degrees lotus thirteen point
one that's close to a full time
load. Here at university
meaning they want to get
through they're not just
slacker it's and just coming
here for a couple classes. The
book of the students here want
to get through and still are
not able to. And yet only
handful of signed up for the-
you know that the cal promise
program so how do you explain
that what's the reason for
that. And so going back to what
I have shared with you we did
start the Dominguez hills first
year experience that is a
program that all of our first
year students participate in.
This started before the
California promise came onto
our campus our transfer
students are also engaged in
the transfer learning
community. And so with that our
students although they're not
participating in the California
promise and one of the things
that I think internally we are.
Taking the time to reflect this
how do we scale this up part of
what I've shared with you is
also having the appropriate.
Human resources and funding to
be able to help us find
increase that. But our students
are part of going back to also
but Jeff said other initiatives
that have been on our campus
all students have participated
coming in when do you Jeff I.
E. transfer students have the
opportunity to participate. In
the transfer learning community
as well. So although that we
don't see the big numbers in
California promise as of now.
There are other initiatives on
our campus that are supporting
our students. Well we're gonna
hear from doctor Wallace's
second I wanna throw props out
his way because when I went to
that too the student union
today for lunch. And I saw all
those wonderful signs talking
about mental health challenges.
And the stresses and strains. I
thought man this is a campus OP
did just put him up today. But
this is a campus that gets it
that it's not just about some
you know isolated like. Try to
find our connection this is
like in your face. We care
about you if you're feeling at.
This this is like. We have a
warm embrace here. Out is that
happening for the California
promise Sir so I gotta get
doctor Wallace to come in to
the California promise program
here because- I'm feeling that
connection on mental health.
But I walk around the campus
yes. And so all of our incoming
students to hear about it on
starting at orientation. It is
shared with them during their
orientation and follow up
workshops. On there also it
also issued with them during
during their advising
appointments. So we do have
various points where students
are hearing it and we are
sharing this information. I
didn't know when you said that
it took about six clicks on our
website to find it. I know that
as a university we have been
looking to connect to
continually improve the way
that Google searches happen on
our website. And so I know that
that's something that we have
undergone but I will go back
and look at that. Occurs doctor
figure I have the six clicks.
Okay well. Then I can make a
bad I can tell you how
difficult it is to find really
I can go through everyone. Just
to find the California promise
program it's almost impossible
honestly it. And I if you don't
have. This you you can go look
it up and I guess I won't
embarrass you by. But we've
done that we looked at six and
you have no idea even how to
even get there you could even
find it again there's no bread
crumbs even finding these six.
I hope that you'll look at that
Jeff. It your students here and
yes it's a diverse student
body. And yes you have more
Pell grant recipients and all
the rest I get all that. They
want to get through in four
years or two years they want to
get through it cost them more
money. Thousands drop out
because they can't. They want
to get through here. There is a
narrative that has been used by
some that says. There's all
these barriers for students all
these demands in their life
they don't really want to get
through now. That they want to
get through here they want to
get that degree because they
know how valuable it is we got
to make it easier for them and
we do as a university recognize
that we do have students on our
campus. And most of them want
to get the route two and four
years and we also recognize
some of the students that. Will
not take you to one four years
and I think it does provide an
opportunity for us to really
look at. The work that we're
doing and how do we continue to
scale the work that we're doing
at Dodd S. center Archuleta
asked a question about datum
almond go. What kind of data
you collect he also asked a
question. About the seniors
that are so close a few classes
away maybe one or two when you
talk about the pay it forward
grants. Can you address those
two questions he asked earlier
terms of what kind of data are
you collecting about why kids
are falling short whether
dropping out what do what do
you know that you can share. So
we have of and a teen. Advice
or or actually couple of
advisers who are working on
reaching out to the students
that have left our institution.
To one find out what why they
have left our institution and
more importantly if they're
looking to come back to our
institution what we have found
it through those efforts it
efforts is that. Many of. The
students to leave because they
have life. That happened. And
dot just spins and then we talk
about okay if your goal is to
come back how do we get you
back onto campus. We do have a
returning Toros workshops that
help students walking through
the process of how to come come
back and reactivate onto our
campus. There are issues that
we do find where it is
financial and it's having that
conversation with students and
walking them through that
process so we are. In in the
stages of collecting that data
and you'll and I think them
important pieces not only
understanding why they have
left and how to help. Them come
back. But it's also being able
to use that information to
prevent future students. From
leaving if we know that these
are the situations that our
students are encountering how
do we- how do we prevent that
from happening moving forward.
And then the second question
I'm sorry what was the- the
data. And then that those that
are so close. A classic two
away sides the pay it forward
brands anything else that
you're doing to. Identify those
seniors that. Are right on the
verge. And I think that our
graduation initiative team of.
Our graduation and an
innovation team is the group
that again. Came up with the
fate the pair we develop the
pay it forward grant and that
team meets once a month. To
really identify those students
that are on. The cusp right
that they have one requirement
one class. In it's not just
about identifying the students
but it's about how do we
support that students in a lot
of cases is that one class.
That is only offered. Every
spring semester and were in the
fall semester right so how do
we work. With the student with
the colleges with their chairs
or where there are with their
majors. To be able to support
the student and completing that
degree so this does happen this
team comes together once a
month. To review some of the
student cases and more
importantly to share best
practices and address ways that
we can support the students
moving forward very good follow
questions Senate Archuleta. Yes
I just wanted to follow up
thank you for your enthusiasm.
If this paper. Right here I'm
looking at it Jeff would you
like to graduate in four years.
Eight you must give us. Fifteen
units per year. Be you must
maintain a C. average. Sign
this contract we'll make it
happen. Just that simple how
many students you think would
sign this from a freshman
class. Just that simple. And I
would imagine just about every
fresh but today. I'll sign that
for years. C. plus. Fifteen
units. But we're not asking up.
In and I think we're here to
try to help. So if a freshman
class came in. And out of two
thousand and a freshman class a
thousand said I. man. You only
have two hundred. Then you need
to ask us. For more faculty.
For another building or two.
You know what we're asking you
to give us more graduates but
we're also asking how. Can we-
and I think this would be a
start because- your answer
provost and everyone should you
want to be more aggressive you
want better numbers. Give us
this. And I'm open to that.
Whatever that might be. And in
thank you so much because I
think that if we do put that
form out there yes we are going
to get a lot of responses but
we also. What we recognize that
our campus is that we want to
build a holistic program and
support to ensure that not only
are they telling as yes but
that we are building all the
support that they need to be
able to move forward and be
successful not only here. On
our campus and beyond our
campus. And I think that the
dilemma that the center
argillite is raising is that.
We're committed to helping but-
more resources and you only
have a hundred and twenty kids.
In the program what is that.
That is that the demand that we
needed now. Deal with with you
know hundreds of thousands of
dollars more when. Somehow we
have to marry those two. If you
have a robust program. We want
to make it successful but if we
don't see a robust program it's
hard to justify the more the
money so somehow we have to.
Work that that issue through.
Alright with that I thank you
very much doctor. For your
great work here on the campus
appreciate it very much. As I
mentioned earlier we have a
great representative from the
academic Senate. A doctor
Charles Thomas thank you Dr
Thomas your being here you're
the chair. Your business law
assistant professor. So I
can't. You advise students
interested in law school which
is fantastic. But we thank you
for your leadership of the
faculty here. And we appreciate
your insight you can bring to
our discussion today thank you.
Thank you senator Glazer the
select committee on such
success. As well as the staff
and volunteers that make the
state. Senate college to a
reality. I want to thank you
for giving me the opportunity
to provide a few words. Our
it's important for us to focus
on the in a relationship
between student success. Often
measured by those graduation
rates. Alongside the bear years
such as hunger. Housing in
security and adequate mental
health counseling and services.
Addict academic success. Not be
pursued without acknowledging
the foundation. Of having
steady housing or enough food
to eat. Not on the chair the
academic Senate here it act C.
S. U. D. H. where are but
business law. For the past.
Moreover I live within walking
distance to the campus
representing an investment in
the long term viability of this
campus and the community it
serves. In many ways I reflect
our student body. Like 63% of
our incoming class I'm the
first in my family to attend
college like 82% of our
incoming class I'm a member of
an under represented minority
group. M. like 70% of our
incoming class I was Appel
recipient throughout college.
Yet despite the similarities
our student body faces a
significantly more expensive
collegiate landscape then when
I attended college. The
Sacramento bee reported on may
first of this year that it
costs close to fourteen times
what it cost forty years ago
back when you senator Glazer
graduated from San Diego state.
And that is adjusted for
inflation. Fourteen times the
cost fifth. Costs this I'm
sorry I raise my voice our
students have been taking a
longer pathway to college
degree. Check your early at the
junior and senior levels
roughly 28% of our juniors in
fall of twenty eighteen
attended part time. In over 30%
of our seniors this represents
double the CSU system wide
average for juniors for fall of
twenty eighteen. In contrast to
our students I went to college
full time taking out loans not
only for tuition but also for
living expenses on campus. I
find our students are far more
conservative in their student
loan choices not taking out the
amount of loans that I felt
comfortable taking out now I
still have educational debt. So
I really can't fault them for
boarding student loans. However.
This leads our students to
enter into the work force
adding additional demands upon
their time. Similarly commuting
the campus keeps our students
within their existing familial
relationships placing yet
another demand think child care
elder care on their time. Some
of the research literature
implies that those with thirty
plus hours of outside
commitment largely work
including caretaking can't
thrive and be successful with
the fifteen unit load per
semester. Now our main unit
load has been improving
currently at twelve point four
for the campus and thirteen
units for incoming freshmen but
we're still not at fifteen. In
this is the context that frames
are four year and six year
graduation numbers. S. faculty
we are proud of the work that
we do with students and C. S.
U. D. H.'s ranked fourth in the
state for social mobility where
students have secured earnings
that are two quart house above.
Their parents earning rates C.
S. UT age is where
transformable social mobility
happens. Faculty is C. S. UT H.
forge pathways to meet the
needs of students for example
sociology professor Katie Pinto
was recognized by the
chancellor's office for her
innovations and graduated
pricing. In addition the
university advising center
works closely with faculty
advisors and mentors for me to
college with several faculty
participating in a fellow it
buys in program. Why we
continue to make strides
towards our graduate initiative
twenty twenty five goals we are
also attempting to address our
long term student needs with
building new dorms on campus.
Transitioning this campus from
principally commuter to
principally residential will
provide students the option to
join a living learning
community on a campus to
minimize those outside
commitments and I just
previously discussed. We're
also making efforts to measure
the level of our basic needs on
the Dominguez hills campus. Our
campus wide survey goes live in
two weeks this will help us to
accurately identify the extent
basic needs are unmet on this
campus we will hopefully inform
campus policy and funding
moving forward. In the mean
time. The campus is engaging in
out reach for its cal fresh
program we are a leader in
affordable learning solutions
for textbooks we are utilizing
a food recovery network for
campus dining and for our
campus farm we have developed a
weekly farmer's market that
brings fresh fruits and
vegetables to the campus
community we've developed a
basic needs act which the
provost has told you a little
bit about. Our and we have
established funds for emergency
housing and pay it forward
grants. But we also know that
the current need outpaces the
supply. At the start of the
semester as academic Senate
chair I. room recommended that
all faculty include in there
still apply resources for food
and housing and secure students
as well as announcing the
upcoming basically survey
student affairs is also
provided the guide of resources
for faculty and staff. To
direct students. S. faculty we
often serve as Sir get support
for students that their
families cannot. Because they
simply have not navigated the
system. This support includes
teaching time management
establishing strong personal
and professional identity and
develop a sense of belonging in
the academic community. In this
sense the faculty are
influential in the development
of our students and remain
committed to their life long
learning. As we say once a Toro
always a Torah. And again thank
you for giving me the option to
speak to the select committee
on student success thank you
thank you doctor Thomas and I'm
up I'm particularly
appreciative of the work that
you and your faculty members of
done on I guess you call
universal learning this were
books don't cost as much as at
the fundamentally what it's
about yes. That they can access
the- the study materials
without this enormous costs
that's a fantastic thing that
you and your colleagues are
doing it's a big deal those are
huge costs for many students
and- I appreciate the work of
your faculty to try to make
that better for kids and I also
want to. Applaud you and your
colleagues for the syllabus
idea and identified in in in
many spaces not just a on a
website we're out those who
have basic needs needs can get
some help so thank you but let
me say I know we have some time
issues here but let me give you
one question. If there were you
have a magic wand now
graduations get two wishes to
improve the four year
graduation. Rate here at to
make this sells well with those
two wishes be. Additional
resources specifically. Toward
making this a residential
campus okay. And in terms of
supplemental instruction
equivalent to what we see in
the first year experience for
the second third and fourth
year grace okay those in those
enhancements to create better
connection and engagement and
support absolutely wonderful
ideas and I'm glad you're
excited about the dorm and I
think that all the folks who
are smarter than me recognize
the advantage of a residential
community and how that can take
care of distractions as you
described. And keep greater
cohesion and add. And
continuing education which was
what we're all striving for so
thank you any any other
questions yes the only member
thank you thank you professor
Thomas you know I. I your your
your comments reminded me when
I was on the. The assembly
budget committee when. Governor
brown then governor brown first
pushed the four year graduation
initiative. You know we all
understood that that if his is
intent was to. Try to open up
more opportunities by by
getting more students in and
out of our universities and
there by. You know a graduating
more students but- there there
was one comment that. That the
governor brown made that I
thought was perhaps reflective
of. The different perspectives
and the different life
experiences that. That we need
to make sure we are listening
to people like you and your
students. You know when you
talked about how. So many of
your students are so busy
working. You know to be able to
put themselves through school.
They don't have time to be at
attending a lot of. Programs
and it reminded me. Governor
brown talked about all. And
back in his day. You know he
took the meandering that road
through life and you explored
in now. In many different ways
but- yeah in the end and it
immediate met the criticism
from many students that were at
that hearing. Saying that we're
not meandering were just too
busy working to put try to put
ourselves school and so. You
know. I mean I. I am listening
to this the station of course
you know we always. You know.
For hueso government market in
and. Faces some of that day the
most challenging economic
circumstances with with your
students and so I. I want to
make sure that that that that.
You know that the policy makers
are in touch with the reality
and I think that's why we're
all here and I want thank you
very much for comes. This state
is the only member I would just
say just in terms of a
statistic that you could point
to. Would be the average age of
our juniors and seniors compare
to the CSU system. Are the
average age of our juniors
based upon fall of twenty
eighteen was twenty five point
three sorry for the point three
of years but- it is. What it
is. Within the system it is
twenty two point nine. So that
difference of two point four
years what difference does that
make well it's called life. And
all the set if you become
betrothed you now have a child
you now have a- fireman to were
you have. The dish familiar
quiet it's the types of. I
feel. That I needed some time.
Will inhibit our ability
despite our best intentions to
get. Jean every single
semester. Just want to provide
that is the context
comparatively to other
campuses. You know again you
could look at ethnicity on this
campus vis a vis other
campuses. There's a number of
different factors I just want
to point to that mitigate
against the ability for all to
graduate fifteen every single
semester just because the life
experience. Okay thank you
thank you very much doctor
Thomas for your great testimony
I want to grant you both of
your wishes. I've deserve their
other fantastic and I certainly
think that we all share those
goals and we'll work together
going forward thank you for
your testimony. I next up up
Morgan Kirk is here you're the
coordinator of. Basic needs
here on the campus as I
understand it you have a
masters of science in higher
education. And higher education
administration another key
thing we've heard earlier used
to work at CSU Northridge.
Owner you. Right I mean. Where
did you go to school I went to
fuller ten and where you come
from before you came here Las
Vegas Nevada okay well let's
use that part. I got a north
ridge. Anyway we welcome you
and look forward to hearing
your about your work here in
the campus thank you. Hello and
thank. No I went out here it
is. Just gonna speak louder
right in the Mike. Can you hear
me now yeah there we go. It was
not that long ago that our
society frequently jokes about
college students surviving on
top Rahman and couch surfing.
Many of us knew that college
students experience food and
housing and securities however
we did not realize how
prevalent it was and we did not
feel quipped or empowered. To
address these challenges. Today
the climate around basic needs
is changing and we truly
appreciate your efforts to
happen tension dialogue.
Regarding what our students are
experiencing and how our
campuses can offer holistic
services to support student
success. I'm sure you all are
familiar with the cal state
chancellor's office basing
these initiatives study. Data
stating that 41% of our
students are experiencing food
insecurity and ten point nine
of our students are
experiencing homelessness
within the once or twice within
the first twelve months. The
study revealed that students
who identify as black African
American and first Jim students
are more likely to experience
housing and securities. Amongst
their peers additionally former
foster you've students are
doubles that number by 24% by
experiencing housing and
securities. This data from the
chancellor's office basing the
study has been extremely
helpful and advancing our
understanding of what our
students need moreover it has
elevated conversations around
what colleges and universities
can do better to support.
Students and in need of food
and housing. Deep the
demographics of our student
body and the preliminary
information we gather from our
via the our basic needs program
we believe that the number of
students experiencing basic
needs challenges I. cal state
Dominguez hills. Is larger than
what the study indicated. The
number of students who have a
role to add D. H. has increased
by 33% by the year two
thousand. This music terms of
people that the number who were
likely to experience basic
needs major by the hello triple
proxy. Has grown by three
thousand five hundred ninety
seven students in the year two
thousand to six thousand and
ninety four and the year two
thousand ten. And eight
thousand eight hundred and
thirty three in the year twenty
nineteen this year. This is a
significant number of students
for whom our campus aims to
provide outreach education
services and follow up. Layered
onto this the campus has a
significant number of first
generation students this is an
indicator that the student is
not likely to know that
resources are available or
where to find them. This number
has also increase from two
thousand nine hundred fifty
five in the year two thousand
to six thousand and ninety five
in the year twenty ten and then
currently eight thousand one
hundred and seventy two this
year. Like many other
institutions in the CSU system.
Our campus has been working
diligently to develop a
comprehensive basic needs
program. In addition to a
current budget request this
will allow us to hire our first
case worker on campus. We are
addressing basing these issues
are Dominguez hills by
maintaining food pantries
providing emergency funds mercy
housing and collecting data to
better understand basic needs
challenges on campus. Our
campus currently has three food
pantries one of our food
pantries provides perishable
items as well as as well as non
perishable items. Are food
pantries receive fresh produce
from my campus urban farm and
local nonprofit organizations.
Over the past academic year we
had thirteen hundred unique
users and have used utilize our
food pantries thirty three
hundred times. We have a cow
fresh food program that
provides students were
application assistance CalPERS
has served over a hundred
eighty eight students this past
academic year. Our students are
able to use their benefits at
our local farmers market and
they're able to utilize the
market match. The market match
program there. For those
students who experience
hardships and do not have
access to any financial
assistance. DH has
institutionalized the faculty
and staff student support grant
in the spring of twenty fifteen
and our students are able to
apply up to a thousand dollars.
Not surprisingly homelessness
fiercely impacts of students
ability to remain in school and
be successful students were
sleeping in their cars faces
serious several issues
including safety nutrition and
hygiene. When students
experience homelessness chances
are all areas of their basic
needs are being compromised
which in turn will impact our
students academic in mental
health. Here at cal state
Dominguez hills homeless
students report being pre
occupied and beat sorry
students a report being pre
occupied by hunger in class
thinking of ways they can find
their next meal and leaving
class to get unhealthy items
from vending machines. In order
to support our students last
year we began offering a mercy
housing for students who
experience housing and
securities we have two one
bedroom units at our university
housing and students are able
to stay there for up to ten
days. We are able to
accommodate those students who
may have children to ensure
that we are serving our
students equally. Those ten
days we work with our students
to connect with them connect
them with our local nonprofit
organization called path which
is people system the homeless.
To identify temporary and rapid
re housing. These students are
follow throughout the year and
or connected to on and off
campus resources. On October
twenty third we are launching a
campus wide basic needs
assessment to a certain the
accurate numbers of students.
Who are experiencing food and
housing and security as well as
mental health and financial
hardships we hope to have those
results available in the spring
semester and then streamline
our programs to be as
responsible as possible to
students needs. If. Hello
there. It is important to me to
reiterate that none of this
would be possible without the
great support we have received
from our local community.
Campus leadership and our
student leaders such as
associate of students I'm
confident that we will continue
to make strides and how we
support students who experience
basic needs challenges. Thank
you again for your time and
advocacy. Thank you thank you
for that review and- certainly
the numbers that you shared
with us our our- more than
disappointing their shocking
and depressing. Thirteen
hundred unique users at your
food bank. The I'm glad that
the work you're doing on
emergency shelter for those
that. Have no other alternative
I'm I'm glad to hear that
you're collecting data this
October twenty third survey is
great. I think we all know how
important that facts are for
making good choices. Going
forward. And if you had two
wishes. That you could be
granted I can imagine why yes
you got one what it what would
they be. I wanna is ongoing
funding for programs so we can
provide sustainable resources
for students. And to assist. To
continue on de stigmatizing
housing and food and security
on campus. And which we are
doing as a program to inform
and educate others on campus
but we want to break down that
barrier so students don't feel
embarrassed to come to our
program to read. Receive the
services that they need for
them to be successful. Yeah
well. Double wishes yeah and-
the application that was cast
that. For food and security to
try to deal with that stigma
issue and the acts that. It
things. Certainly is a step
forward there and- I'm when you
talk about I'm going Monning.
What what part do you have with
the county. I mean are they
partners in what you're doing I
resources that we give to
counties that they receive are
they are they coming here to
the campus to feel like your
connection is. On the funding
side with the county is
together are Dennis students is
currently in the room so he'll
be able to answer that. Our our.
That your choice at your option
Jean it's nice to have you here.
He's right is that the above my
pay grade question kind of yes.
They need to do that I'm sorry
no you're fine. Just talk loud
into it okay so right now are
really the basic needs program
is still really in its infancy
and we don't. Necessarily have
a strong partnership with the
county in terms of access to
funding what we have done up to
this point is look at
partnerships to immediately
solve some more of the more
immediate needs of students
around housing and food. And so
do our basic needs initiative a
committee on campus we've been
in conversations about how we
can better leverage what we're
doing here with our local part
partners including our city and
county partners and so that it
that's on our radar that we're
looking to take advantage of as
we move forward I encourage you
to do. That because what it's
something that we have heard
our campus tours and other
places where a lot of times
that the college campuses are
seen as like islands like it's
we don't have to go there they
kind of got their stuff
together. And the counties
completely ignored forgetting
that if you're responding your
basic needs of your community
you can't just say that them
and not us and we got a we got
to reestablish that partnership
and that obligation there so I
hope that you work on that yeah
absolutely. Thank you I thank
you very. Jean anything else.
Yes if I could just follow up
on that so what steps. Does
Dominguez hills take to
identify the students who are
cal fresh eligible. So do you
want Anthony women he yeah
steps wikihow fresh the end
what what steps you take to
identify the students who are
cal fresh eligible and what
would you do to encourage them
to apply yeah of course so
couple ways that we try to make
sure that students are eligible
is that we meet them where
they're at so our coverage and
turns are currently in
different departments. As you
may know we do have a coverage
how fresh eligibility for
students so if they have cal
grant a RB they may look
eligible if they work twenty
hours per week or eighty hours
per month they may look
eligible if they are part of I.
Toro guardian scholars foster
you or are your P. programs
they may look eligible. And so
our students are also at the
forefront at our farmers market
so they can applied there so
those are some ways that we're
trying to catch the students in
C. they may look triple another
resource that we provide within
our basing these programs
called a hot meal program and
so students are able to receive
this fifty dollar card but in
order for them to receive it
they have to go there khao
freshen C. they are eligible
for some benefits. So that's
another way or another step
that we are taking to ensure
that students are. Obtaining
sustainable food while they're
here D. H. that are Bradford.
Doctor but in all corners get.
Okay very good well thank you
for all your good work here. On
the campus in such an important
area that should not have any
stigma to it whatsoever. And
speaking of unfair statements.
It's a great lead and the
doctor Wallace in your work and
the whole mental health issue
and again my- my compliments
for engaging the community and
one way in which we saw. Just
today and- just speaking
honestly about mental health
and mental health challenges
and eliminating that stigma
issue. Which is unfairly placed
on those who are stressed. But
we welcome you you're a
psychologist here in the campus.
Usually the efforts and mental
health and we welcome your
testimony. Well first of all
like to thank you senator
Glazer and- the- select
committee for give me the
opportunity. To speak about on
mental health issues and the
way in which we addressed those
here at Dominguez hills so. I
guess I would like to I've
heard a lot about like the four
year graduation process and
I've been thinking a lot about
that and what could be.
Interfering with that and is it
has me thinking a lot about
like my own Jerry. I went I was
scholarship students so I went
to school in the four years and
in in the scholarship for
undergrad. But my graduate
journey was a little bit more
difficult and it took a little
bit longer. And when I reflect
back on that I think one of the
major challenges was something
Connie imposter syndrome. And
that was a lack of belief in
myself a lack of belief that I
deserve to be a doctor. And I
think they got no way of me
pursuing it as quickly as I
could. With that comes a lot of
data a lot of anxiety fear when
you're at the finish line do I
want to step out in. Not have
to do this is Bob along here.
And I think a lot of our
students here to make you still
struggle with that as well. You
know. The sense of do they
belong today deserve to be
seen. Today deserve to have
these things that they haven't
had. Into their lives on it so
a big part of the work that
we've done is to reduce stigma.
But also to empower students to
recognize that. They have
important voices important
contributions to the world.
They're. Not just. Afterthought.
So I would like to talk a
little bit about the services
that we do provide here. At the
counseling center so we do
individual sessions group
sessions we do crisis
interventions so if a student
is coming in with. Some acute
crises they can come in and be
seen that day. To just that
issue. Aren't we also focus a
lot on outreach. And senator
Glazer you were speaking to the
earlier where you saw the ways
in which we kind of push the
message out there. And let the
students know that we're here
to serve them. That's something
that's a huge passion of my own
because I found that. In order
to get reduced at stake my
number in to increase the level
of comfort in being seen. By a
therapist you got another
therapist is. You know the
students need to see our faces
and see that we're we're normal
people. You know. It's just the
conversation. And once. They're
able to connect the face to
those services it becomes much
more comfortable much more
easier process within the
coming in is and be helped by
us. On and it's also a great
opportunity to kind of just
educate students in the public
as a whole about. Mental
health. It take away this kind
of false idea that. You know
Mitchell health struggles are
something that other people
have. When in fact all of us
can relate to anxiety all of
the related depression. And so
it's a good way to kind of just
like normalized that in just
let students know that if they
are experiencing things like
that that's not a sign that you
don't belong here. That is the
side your normal human being
and we have ways to help you
with that. And so. That's a big
focus of ours just getting that
getting that. Message out
there. Something else I'd like
to bring up to is in my work
with students I've noticed that
like. Not only life hidden away
in terms of like having to
work. But Sirius trauma like
our students are dealing with.
Real actual trauma. That a lot
of our students are coming from
communities where there's
violence. Live where there's
life or death issues going on.
So those type of things kind of
like. If we think about
hierarchy of needs right. You
know we need food we need
shelter but we need to live and
stay alive. And so if you're
focused on that if you're
focused on just surviving is
very hard to kind of like had
those extra mental resources
available to do your algebra
homework. Or things of that
nature. And so for one many of
us in the center we wanted to
get like special we're wanting
to really focus on that Tom and
help his students process that
trauma. So they can take away
that have a place to kind of.
The deal with that extra layer
of psychological psychological
stress and burden. That could
interfere with just the ability
to pay attention in class and
things of that nature. So
because we're short on time I
like to just open up the floor
for any questions you may have
thank you doctor Wallace and I
think that the reason. That
we're talking about mental
health is because for many of
us we recognize that it it can
be as important as food and
housing it is that important
and that statement doesn't
belong. And can you I don't
wanna put you on the spot can
you tell me how big of a staff
you have here at the at the
university dealing in your
counseling center. Up we have
approximately ten of full time
counselors and asked taking
like if we combine some of the
halftime counselors that's how
we get that number of ten. And
if I'm a student and I'm
stressed out very stressed out
and I call and I said like to
come in for an appointment how
long when I have to wait to get
an appointment. Act honestly
that depends on like the time
of year that you Connie and so
like there's certain high
periods. Like let's say mid
terms finals where we have a
higher demand on our services.
A in times like that there
could be a significant weight
time up between four to eight
weeks right. I wanted to get
the I wanted you to put that on
the record because it's- it's a
four day weeks they're right
here that four to eight weeks.
Just not acceptable. No that's
not your fault I'm not don't
get me wrong hidden but that
that's not acceptable. And I we
we've heard that when I was a
trustee at the time at least.
The testimony was that on
average in the state among the
twenty three campuses. The
average wait time for students
says I need some help. With
three weeks. Andy here to make
a sales when I look at the
ratio of students to
counselors. It's way below
average yeah that's not good
that's not your fault but
that's the reality here. Is a
lot yeah sockets and I. Just
wanna I want to say that. It
resource demands are everywhere
on campus I get that we
understand that. And if there's
things that we need to do in
the legislature to help with
that issue. I'm certainly want
to step up first to be that
help because- we have got to
make sure that if kids are
stressed out. Not suicidal
there's a difference in I know
that you would recognize that
difference but- we cannot
happen waiting four to six
weeks. To get help that keeps
them in in school it literally.
Keep them in school happened
drop out because they can't
take it. And the signs that you
had out there today was very
powerful. Would you share a
couple those messages the
reality check on. The stressed
out nature of your student body
can you share some of those
facts that you have on the
sign. I don't know the exact
factory assigned record to
speak from my experiences
there. The number one thing
that our students. Are
struggling with is this
anxiety. That's the number one
thing that students are coming
in for. Particularly things
like testing side. You know.
And I think again that ties
back to like struggles. In
terms of like believe that they
belong that I'm here to do this
you know. If you're struggling
with that self belief. Of any
kind of set back in a class
like a bad. Scored a testament
to sign me can reinforce this
is that I don't know if this is
for me. And so I think anxiety
is the number one driver was
bringing students into our
services. Also I think. A lack
of sense of community. Right a
sense of isolation because it's
a huge transition coming from
high school to university. N.
transitions always bring stress
with them and so I think.
Experience in those those
transitions and the stress that
come with those transitions
kind of again fuels that
anxiety innocence of
disconnection the students on
can feel on campus so I think a
steps in as as a community is a
very important thing as well.
So I took a couple pictures
some of the sign messages. One
of them says that 76% of your
students felt physically
exhausted within the last
twelve months seven six
percent. Here's another one.
35% I felt so depressed. That
it was difficult for them to
function within the last twelve
months 35% said they were so
depressed was difficult Steven
function. There was another one
on how many students you have
contemplated suicide do I
recall it right around 14% your
number. Yeah so these are these
are real powerful and scary and
worries some facts. And I hope
and I hope that we in the
legislature in partnership with
the campus can can do more. You
need more help yes I'm I need
more staff definitely okay. We
mostly got to find a way
through that pathway it's very
very important he so we're
gonna open we're gonna close in
just a moment. But I want to
mention that at all of our
public hearings in the Senate
and the assembly we have an
opportunity for public hearing.
For anyone who would like to
share some thoughts with us and
we're going to provide for that
in just a moment. But I want to
give my colleagues on the panel
the chance to ask any follow up
questions and then closing
remarks. Well first off I'd
like to say thank you to
everyone. But I'd like to
apologize. I'd like to
apologize. Because. When we
started I said I wanted to
listen. And not only did I
listen but I heard you loud and
clear. You're dealing with
students that come from all
kinds of background the
diversity. That is here number
one. In the system as far as
diversity. The need financial
economic that that is
devastating and somehow full.
Of and you're dealing with
every kind of student. So we
may have walked in here gave me
the impression was. Why aren't
these numbers right. Why are
these numbers I see. Nine point
five when I looked down the
list and- and I C. San Diego at
forty six point six. I see she
co at ninety twenty nine fuller
Janet twenty five in your at
night. You may have thought
that's how we came in. Well
maybe we get I apologize for
that because now I know that if
you had the scale balance. In a
lot of different ways this
thing would get the other way
around. You would be in that
eighty and ninety percent.
Sorry. Because I had mentioned
earlier that I had to send to
graduate from west point. And
then I tell you about my one of
my daughters. And she graduated
from Chapman college but she
graduated with four kids. And a
husband that they had. Some
physical problems because of an
accident and she would not stop
going to school yes I help yes
my wife and I bush the bush she
had the family when she finally
made it but with four kids in
the classroom sometimes so
imagine that scale so I've told
her that you get a much better
than your brothers. At west
point it didn't have to worry
about tuition you have to worry
about anything but you had to
worry about those for kids so.
You've changed my mind I tell
you the support that I wanna
root for and fight for is not
just the academics on this side
but the things that you need
you need additional teachers
you need professor you need
more help financially you need
these kids will be able to
survive that last few months so
we're gonna look into that and
I'm going to recommend that. To
senator Glazer that we could
help in a lot of different ways
these numbers will change to
god bless you for what you're
doing you're taking this
challenge. And you meet it head
on. Thank you. So I wanna let
the other colleagues at some
closing remarks M. ago that
senator Bradford and assembly
member next. Again let me think
US senator Glazer for putting
this hearing on to give him a
round of applause for. This
important issue our students
six Josh. And we heard a lot of
challenges and obstacles that
error impeding a student's.
Ability to graduate and it's
clear that we have to refocus
our priorities the
legislature's well because for
the last twenty years our main
focus has been about admissions
getting your number's up
getting your numbers out. For
the most important are just as
important is getting those
graduation numbers up and we
have to refocus our priorities
now because we've been talking
about admission since ward
Connelly and how do we- provide
a diverse student body but-
it's not enough to get him in
the door we got to get a mop.
Toward well as graduate so
that's going to be I party and
I knows senator Glazer about
the remediation and that's of
great importance because the
legislative black caucus were
our service device year. We did
a tour two years ago and
visited a variety of students
throughout the state of
California and we realize.
Regards to work that kid in
front of you. It's far more
clear she was far more likely
to remediate and repeat classes
that they had already taken.
Yet ance calculus you name it
AP courses they had to do it
more so than their counterparts
and I think it speaks to
something we fell to talk about
as well when we look at these
numbers and when I saw the nine
percent. I wasn't judging cal
state Dominguez hills but I can
implicit bias that we face.
People of color. And
educational system and housing
and all those challenges so
that's the issue that needs to
be talked about as well M.
needs to be addressed implicit
bias that still exist. And our
education system. And how do we
fix that and it won't be
overnight but it's gonna be
through. Being willing to have
honest dialogue. And I and
working with individuals such
as yourself to deal with this
on a daily basis so I'm
recommitted myself as a- alarm
of this fine university I know
what that commitment is. No
hard work you're doing to. Take
message out and recruit young
people who are have the biggest
challenges some time to get to
college and we need to find a
way to X. I'll he did have one
question. Of the housing the
units. That you have are they
pretty much bill your round.
Honestly it just really depends
on when our students need it
but I. Spring semester was
filled for the whole semester.
Great thank you center Bradford
thank you for your great
leadership and yeah and passion
in higher education and
certainly for Dominguez hills
thank you very much for being
here SLA member to G. thank you
for being here thank you. I
just wanna wrap up by the
thanking everyone for a- your
presentation I think one of the
challenges that we face. As as
California lawmakers is that in
a while we are working so hard
to expand access to. Higher
education opportunities for
all. That as as- you know
college education has become.
You know what used to be
primarily the province of the
middle class. In in decades
past that now we are. You know
reaching out and bringing in.
You know because so many
diverse populations with with
different challenges and I and
I think your presentations
really. You know reminded us
that that with. The expanded
axis comes expanded challenges
and expand across. It all right
I wanted to follow up good
looks like we're running out of
time I know what. Sir Glazer
try to move things along here
but that doctor Wallace I love
to talk to you more later on.
Because you know. Like my- my
district I represent you know
some some very low income
working class communities. A
harbor city harbor gateway. But
also. Very affluent communities
man at these pelts for. M. L.
on this issue mental health
it's just. I am just trying to
figure out why they Atkins ID.
Precedence side is spot being a
all different communities. But
I mean. Things yeah I mean I
had things when I was a kid
what's different now you know.
What is it that that anxiety
depression suicide express
biking. Not all in the aft
communities man at beach palace
Verdes. But also in. Here are.
With your students at the thing
is stills and so. You know
there's this whole conversation
is really. And highlighting the
need for a for policy makers
you know what's happening. On
the ground and I for the
following. Thank you very.
Which I'm looking forward to
and more conversations could
happen as we walk around campus
but if you'd like to please.
Identify yourself if you wish
and let us have your thoughts.
Good afternoon and thank you
for coming to Dominguez hills
my name is Carolyn to no go.
And I'm a graduate student
studying public administration
you're entering a sales we're
also earned my undergrad degree
in business. Little fact about
myself is that I enjoy taking
surveys. When I transfer to
Dominguez hills. It from City
College of San Francisco
answered an email that
contained a survey entitled the
C. S. U. food and housing.
Housing security survey. That
survey. Search hello. Now we
all know that one in every four
CSU student is food insecure
and one in every ten our
housing and secure. I myself am
currently housing and secure
and don't have permanent.
Residency due to high cost
right. Basic needs and so basic
needs support and mental health
care is vital for students
successful and because I'm very
passionate about. I currently
serve as the AS I. director of
legislative affairs. And last
year I was the executive vice
president for finance for the
cal state student association.
I've shared my story of food
and security as well because at
one point during my undergrad
years I held for part time jobs
during the semester just to
make ends meet. Students should
not have to print choose
between graduation or
groceries. Since the basic
needs basic needs conference
that happened in Sacramento in
two thousand eighteen. I mean
it does has made great strides
in addressing stern Gaines. We
have three food pantries a hot
meal card program. Graham an
urban farm and a market match
program at a farmer's market
for students who currently have
coverage benefits. I also
currently work part time as the
caliphate food coordinator on
campus. During the first week
of school me and my intern
signed up over forty five
students for cal fresh
benefits. But there's still
more we can do. Passing
legislation that makes the cal
fresh program a more seamless
process for students. So they
can be approved for more
benefits can help more funding
for the cal grant program so
that students can have access
to financial aid. Art and here
on campus opening a larger food
pantry would definitely help
us. I know that everyone in
this room cares about this
issue. And we should all you
need to come together to find
innovative ways to ensure all
to me still still still safe
secure and supported. Thank you
again for your time thank I
thank. Thank. Thank you for
sharing your personal story as
well as your leadership on this
issue on the app is very much
appreciated thank you so much.
Yes. Hello my name is hawk make
beds and I am the graduate
research in terms of the basic
needs department I'm also my
master's thesis is funded in
part by the chancellor's office
and basic needs grants. I'm
encouraged that psychological
wellness is part of the basic
needs conversation now. Of and
I want to also suggest that
financial wellness be included
in the Maslow hierarchy
actually my live park you could
probably be. Dismissed and-
favor of a more holistic
solution. Including financial
wellness environmentalists
which can address the
environments that our students
are coming from as well as
transportation issues. I want
to suggest cultural wellness be.
Part of psychological wellness
but its own so culturally
competent courses and of
environment that is gorgeous.
Culturally competent and
culturally responsive to our
students from where they come
from. And also social wellness
which includes childcare which
is a real need I'm very
preliminary findings from a
study that I'm doing right now
points to child care. As one of
the life things that happens
I'm not just having a child but
dealing with when they get sick
where do we put them when
they're on spring break and
we're not. I'm as far as
becoming. Pretty campus which
I'm really I'm a big fan of
that wording and that mission.
Over the summer as the former
cal fresh coordinator over the
summer I worked well worked
with them the foundation on our
campus and with campus dining
to try to get easy T.
implemented on our campus and
EBT readers are students can
have a place. To spend their
cow fresh dollars currently
there's no guidance from the
that I could find from the
chancellor's office or from the
state to the systems. To try to
streamline that process and I'm
not sure if I would just wasn't
looking in the right places or
not. But I basically. It and
there's no personal key point
person within the financial
management system that it would
be required to do that or would
have that guidance to do that
and it's basically up to
whoever at the university from
what I've been able to see can
do that. Some of the people
that were helping our student
workers and you may or may not
know that student workers are
restricted to twenty hours a
week. So they're not able to
work a full time job. Many of
those students are also. Some
of the ones were sleeping in
their cars and are worried
about whether meal is going to
be coming from. So what can we
do as far as student worker
rates go increasing those maybe
relaxing that our requirement I
don't know what the solution is
I know that their students are
in need though. I appreciate
the fact the efforts our
faculty and of being de facto.
Psychologists when they're on a
six week waiting time I know I
use them. As as such I'm not
sure if they're- prepared for
that all the time. I understand
that when you have you really
want to increase awareness for
programs that are on campus.
It's really hard to do that
when you have one person
running your programs of. As
far as. Increasing if we're
going to be. Of student
centered scampers but has
students living on campus we
need to create. Faculty of I'm
sorry family housing. As well
as a dining hall. And the last
thing that I haven't heard
mentioned in this entire
hearing is the needs of
undocumented and makes that a
student's. They are not
eligible for cal for ash or
many state and county. Services
and there and the most of some
of the most need they're eating
out of the candy dishes
sometimes. So this concludes my
thoughts thank you thank you
thank you hi thank you for
coming and sharing. Thoughts.
All right anyone else before we
close the public hearing part
of our- alright. Well let me
just say in summing up but
thank you to the university for
having us here provost back.
Thank you. For all your
hospitality and that of your
staff doctor goal thank you for
your continuing work on the
system. Our graduation
initiative doctor Figueroa
thank you for your work here on
the campus. More conversation
still to have. A doctor Thomas
thank you in the faculty again
and the staff for all the to
help. Make our students
successful. Miss Kirk thank you
for the great work in basic
needs that you do. And doctor
Wallace thank you for. This
bringing us some start
testimony that's very important
that the apart all the
conversations we have. About
student success. I'm I know
this that that Dominguez hills
is a very special university
here in California. And
California as a state cannot be
successful. Unless Dominguez
hills is successful that means
all the students that are
enrolled here on the campus.
And I think all of us are
committed to doing everything
we can in partnership. To make
our university here even more
successful. So that every
student can thrive at every
level. Because they have a roof
over their head because they
have food. In their stomach
because we're taking care. Of
mental challenges that they may
face. And because we've created
pathways for success. To your
pathways for transfers. Four
year pathways. For freshmen
students we can do that and I
know you're all committed to it
so I think all those who have
participated here in the
audience and those watching.
And with that ladies and
gentleman are a- hearing is
adjourned